Hãy phía hợp ngày 12, bộ chính trị đã xem xác tự trình của đảng vì bộ nông về và mù trường.
Về đean đều trình của hại xử dụng lất khúc ra thời ghi hàng hình của trong này mốt,
hàng hình của trong bác mùi, tâm dinh đến năm hàng hình của trong năm mùi.
Bộ chính trị ra đảng hủy chính phủ, chỉ đào đảng vì bộ nông về và mù trường,
phối hợp cùng các cơ quan, cần trường xơ kết về thực hiện nghị quế số mề tảm của ban chá phản Trung hương đảng
bởi tiếp tục đổi mởi hoàn thiện thị trễ chính xác, nâng cao nhở lực thiệu qua quan lý và sự dụng đất,
tạo đồng lực đất nước gà trở thành nước phát triển có thù nhập cao.
Để đean xuất dựa đổi cân cơ chính xác đất đài, chính hội nghỉ Trungua Bà xem xác cho ý kiến,
trên cơ sở đó, đean xuất dựa đổi đổi đất đài để chính của hội xem xác quyền.
Đồng thời tiếp tục ra soát bộ dùng và hoàn thiện, phương án đều trình quy khai sự dụng đất,
báo cáo bộ chính trị những lỗi dùng và thống quyền.
Bộ chính trị rao đàn quy chính phủ.
Biết thưa đằng quy chính phủ.
Thủ trưởng chỉ đạo các các quan kết thồi hiện các bộ chính trị, bản biết thư.
Để hoàn thiện đean.
Thử giatm phen phen phùa điều trình của hạc xử dụng đất của giả theo quy định của phá lợt trước ngày 1 thành bẩy.
Nảm ảnh hành khu trang haisal.
Kụm về đó tiếp tục giải quyết giận Gương Máp Phát triển trong thực hiện theo quy định.
Không làm cản trở phát triển kinh tế xác hội.
không để chục lợi chính xác, thầm nhóm lấy nhóm hoặc thức hoa các xay phạm khác,
đàn hoi chính vụ chỉ đào đàn vì mộ nông như vào môi trường,
thần chương ra soát dẫn tích đất lỗi đất dừng,
bà đầm đúng đủ về số liệu và hiện chàng,
phục vô công các quản lý, sự dụng hiệu quả tiếp kiệp,
dự thảo lợi xưa đổi dự kiến tập trung và 2 nhóm lửa dùng lớn,
thuy nhất, nhóm các lửa dùng đáp ứng yêu cầu về phát triển đất nước,
trong kỳng nguyên mới và yêu cầu tăng trường kinh tế 2 còn số,
thứ 2, nhóm các lửa dùng quy định về phần cấp phần quyền,
phần định thầm quyền theo mô hình chính quyền được phương 2 cấp,
cải các hình chính trong lý vụnh đất đai.